C'est
[Musique]
la samba de Minha Terra laisse les gens
reviens quand tout le monde chante bole
tout le monde sèche tout le monde Samba da Minha
La Terre nous a dit de la musique de gâteau Tout va bien
Quand tout le monde chante, qui ne chante pas ?
aime la samba bon gars n'est pas mauvais
de la tête
ou pied malade
Je ne sais pas comment m'asseoir et travailler et
Je pensais que tu étais fou de Samba
Je ne me suis jamais séparé juste sur ma jambe
bon message quand tu chantes tout
bon monde quand tout le monde chante
faire sortir la samba de Minha Terra
des gens doux quand tu chantes tout va bien
Quand tout le monde chante, qui ne chante pas ?
il aime la samba, un bon gars, n'est-ce pas ?
c'est trop dans la tête
ou pied malade
Je suis né je vais à la samba dans la samba et
Creer de do danado do Samba
Je ne vais pas m'asseoir allons-y tous
mot
dans
Dieu est la base de la loi la vie est un grand
carnaval
tu dis de ne rien dire
[Musique]
C'est
elle parle pour ne pas parler au
mon père emmène Jésus à
les gens ont raison
dans le retard que Dieu est la base Lire mon
la vie est un si grand travail est
[Musique]